vielleicht geht dieser sommer in die
geschichtsbücher ein amerika europa
afrika asien
der klimawandel ist zum greifen in
schweden also in schweden nur noch mal
zur erinnerung das ist das land im hohen
norden geraten waldbrände außer
kontrolle in deutschland hatten wir den
heißesten april und den heißesten seit
beginn der wetteraufzeichnungen und so
ist es weltweit von überall werden
rekorde gemeldet und aus dem iran
die ersten aufstände es wird schlimm es
ist der wahnsinn klick zum science
fiction herzlich willkommen
[Musik]
30 grad und mehr und das seit wochen
viele fragen sich schon ob das
vielleicht der neue jahrhundert sondern
wird seit mehreren wochen herrscht dürre
in vielen regionen deutschlands und vor
allem für den osten und norden bedeutet
dass eine schleichende wetter
katastrophe ist die dürre 2018
vergleichbar mit dem jahrhundertsommer
2003 bei dem mehrere 10.000 menschen
starben
wie ungewöhnlich ist diese trockenheit
für deutschland und kommen in der
zukunft weitere wetterkatastrophen auf
uns zu die aktuelle wetter katastrophe
spielt sich vor allem von emden bis zum
erzgebirge ab der westen und süden die
haben dagegen in der vergangenen zeit
mit krassen regenfällen ja fast
sturzfluten zu kämpfen gehabt vor allem
osten deutschlands hat der wassermangel
und die daraus entstehende katastrophale
folgen einige regionen sind so trocken
wie seit dem beginn der
wetteraufzeichnung noch nie in sachsen
anhalt und thüringen ist der boden bis
zu zwei meter tief ausgetrocknet auch im
norden gibt es eine schwere schwere
dürre bis tief in den boden hinein in
niedersachsen kamen die wasserwerke
nicht mehr hinterher um den wasserbedarf
aus eigener kraft zu stemmen doch bei
allen grund zur sorge steht auch fest
die versorgung mit trinkwasser in
deutschland ist wirklich nur in
ausnahmefällen gefährdet in anderen
regionen der welt ist das anders im iran
sind 97 prozent des landes von
anhaltender trockenheit betroffen in
mehreren städten dort gibt es einfach
kein trinkwasser mehr die bevölkerung
protestierte dagegen es sollen bei
auseinandersetzungen mit der polizei
demonstranten erschossen worden seien
angeblich ist ein rohrbruch schuld doch
der iran leidet unter einem fehler im
system hervorgerufen durch den
klimawandel
die temperaturen stiegen hier bereits
doppelt so stark als im durchschnitt auf
der erde um bis zu zwei grad der
wasserverbrauch ist dabei immens die
vereinten nationen empfehlen 20 prozent
der wassermenge zu verbrauchen die durch
regen wieder aufgefüllt wird im iran
sind es 110 prozent dem land geht
einfach das wasser aus es wird wohl
nicht mehr vermeidbar sein dass zwölf
von 31 provinzen in naher zukunft
unbewohnbar werden die folgen durch
hunger revolten und damit die
instabilität der ganzen region
nach europa doch selbst hier in europa
wird es unangenehm gerade ist der pegel
der elbe in dresden auf 55 zentimeter
gefallen und auch andere flüsse in
betroffenen gebieten führen deutlich
weniger wasser als sonst die folgen bei
uns der warenverkehr über die flüsse ist
gar nicht mehr oder nur eingeschränkt
möglich beispielsweise zwischen dresden
und magdeburg das alles wird jetzt auf
die straßen beziehungsweise schiene
verlagert was deutlich mehr kostet und
oft auch mehr zeit in anspruch nimmt
eine andere folge der hitze hier
pflanzen sterben ab und brände haben
bereits mehrere hundert hektar wald
verwüstet was aber nichts gegen die
waldbrand katastrophe in schweden ist
insgesamt gibt es dort 50 waldbrände
das ist so ein seltenes ereignis also
überhaupt ein waldbrand in schweden dass
schweden gar keine löschflugzeuge
besitzt und die absolute katastrophe
15 dieser waldbrände können nicht mehr
gelöscht werden sie sind vollkommen
außer kontrolle geraten
und wenn man sich die wettervorhersagen
ansieht werden sie noch wochen brennen
regen wird es so bald nicht geben
in deutschland bringt dass die landwirte
in bedrängnis das wichtigste getreide in
deutschland ist der weizen und in vielen
regionen müssen die bauern die felder
viel früher ernten und das obwohl die
körner noch lange nicht so weit sind
manche bauern ernten bis zu 40 prozent
weniger getreide als normal und auch die
rapsernte fällt wohl deutlich kleiner
aus als sonst einige landwirte müssten
so um ihre existenz fürchten so der
bauernverband er fordert dass in
betroffenen gebieten den notstand
ausgerufen wird schon jetzt werden
vergleiche mit 2003 laut ein extrem
trockenes jahr mit einer gewaltigen
hitzewelle
august 2003 gab es in europa
temperaturen bis zu rund 47 grad man
muss sich das mal so biologisch vor
augen führen das ist zehn grad mehr als
unsere körpertemperatur also wirklich
gefährlich eine der größten
naturkatastrophen die der kontinent je
gesehen hat flüsse waren ausgetrocknet
wälder abgebrannt und zehntausende
menschen starben es traf vor allem
ältere leute denn klimaanlagen versagten
und die
häuser waren überfüllt mit zu opfern
aber auch 2018 hat es in sich schon seit
dem frühling hält in den entsprechenden
gebieten das muster an sonniges wetter
mit trockener luft und diese
hochdruckgebiete werden kaum durch regen
unterbrochen stabile wetterlage
hervorgerufen durch langsamer werdende
jetstreams um die arktis die für immer
weniger luft bewegung sorgen
eine folge des klimawandels doch wie
ungewöhnlich ist solch eine trockenheit
in deutschland wirklich anfällig für
wassermangel
so hatte die un deutschland 2015 in
ihrem wasser bricht eingestuft doch es
gibt möglichkeiten das zu überbrücken
die versorgungsinfrastruktur in unserem
land ist im gegensatz zu anderen ländern
und kontinenten gut und betroffene
regionen können einfach über
fernleitungen mit wasser versorgt werden
der großraum stuttgart ist
beispielsweise abgesichert durch das
anzapfen des bodensees gleich mehrere
talsperren und trinkwasserspeicher
versorgen das ruhrgebiet doch in zukunft
werden probleme mit trockenheit und
dürre nicht kleiner werden im gegenteil
der niederschlags zyklus im mittel
europa verschiebt sich schon seit jahren
hin immer mehr ins extreme im winter
haben die regenmengen demnach rund um
zehn prozent zugenommen
deutlich trockener dagegen präsentieren
sich die sommermonate regionale
klimamodelle bestätigen dass und
prognostizieren für deutschland eine
höhere wahrscheinlichkeit für längeren
trockenphasen ja wie geht es also vor
allem in diesem jahr hier in deutschland
und auch weltweit weiter wir bleiben
dran wenn er kein video dazu und zu
allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
dann endet mich bei whatsapp also klicks
um dann umgeht er die kapuze am boxi auf
youtube und ihr verpasst kein video denn
über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
persönlich von jedem upload und zwar
noch vor allen anderen täglich und
garantiert ein verliert auf klicken und
am besten auch mein schwesterkanal
klicks um social media abonnieren da
gibt es das neueste aus der social media
welt dafür
hier klicken aber nicht die höhe auf
blogger vergessen
hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken klimawandel bestätigt
skeptiker endgültig widerlegt bis dann
bleibt dran